does my talking about this count as
YouTube drama
again nah this is Corporate nonsense I
never get tired of
[Music]
that hey folks so it's the timing of
these things are very fun
what was originally going to go up today
and it's still going to happen I've
already shot it but it's just going to
happen later because it's a little bit
of an evergreen topic um I was going to
be talking about sort of uh some of the
corporate machinations that lend
themselves to just a lot of crap the
general premise of things costing more
and you getting less uh that whole thing
uh that I'm bumping because something
more localized YouTube happened that
enables me to talk about a very specific
wedge of corporate
BS we're going to talk about The
Escapist now if you don't know who they
are if you don't know what that website
what that Channel or any of the people
involved in it are I'm hoping you'll
still stick around because I'm going to
give you the context you need but I'm
also going to put it into context of
some other stuff you might have heard of
and just talk overall about why this
happens because this is all a very
natural
outcropping of our incredibly
Consolidated um capitalist H driven
world this is what happens when almost
everything has a parent company almost
no uh entity that is self- sustaining is
truly independent once it reaches a
certain level and size like there are
some obviously YouTube there are a fair
number but a lot of things that you
think okay but that's that's a
profitable self- sustaining business
isn't it well it might be doesn't matter
because it's owned by somebody else
whether or not they're successful will
not determine whether or not they have a
future I'll explain all this as we go so
let's get some context in here first
little bit of history on The Escapist it
was originally a digital magazine it's
has always specialized in gaming content
be it reviews breaking news development
stories Etc things of that nature it's
also covered some stuff in regards to
say movies and things like that but it's
primarily gaming focused and pretty much
always has been in 2007 they started
putting out uh video content on a
YouTube channel uh also hosting it on
their own site and it was primarily done
by contractors the most famous of which
is yatsi croshaw who created Zero
Punctuation which has always been the
biggest draw of not only the the YouTube
channel but of The Escapist website as a
whole Zero Punctuation being 5 to 6
minute long animated very Punchy fastpac
and highly critical reviews of video
games I know I only just got on board
the Dark Souls Pain Train choo choo All
Aboard for driving straight into a brick
wall but no one's more critical of
drinking than a former alcoholic and yes
I did just imply that not being into
Dark Souls is equivalent to a major
destructive personality flaw I've
enjoyed Yi's work for a while I've Nam
dropped him a few times and reference
other things I've even used a clip of
his stuff at least once if you know it's
bad why are you doing it but some other
people who might be names you recognize
that did get involved with The Escapist
for a while there was Stephanie Sterling
with the gym quisition there's Miracle
of Sound um both of whom have been
independent for a very long time but
they initially were uh on The Escapist
as it was on YouTube now The Escapist
has not been drama-free in its lifetime
starting around 2011 there started being
tensioned with various elements and
parts and creators involved in it and
some of them starting splitting away
that included Stephanie Sterling that
included folks like Bob Chipman uh movie
Bob I don't want to dig into him too
much he's people have very strong
opinions on him and I don't want to get
into it but you know he was part of that
group but they all started breaking away
eventually to the point that pretty much
the only output of the YouTube channel
and the primary draw of the website
itself was just yatsi it was just zero
punctuation or whatever side project
yatsi did for a while things like uh
judging by the cover hello ladies and
welcome to judging by the cover where
we'll be judging Spectre by the poster
during this period when it was kind of
hemorrhaging creatives they were either
quitting or being let go or not having
contracts renewed the parent company of
The Escapist was sold to defy media now
in 2018 The Escapist was sold to
Enthusiast gaming who brought back some
of the old folks not many of whom stayed
but basically attempted to re launch and
bring it back to its earlier Glory Days
before everybody started jumping ship
that started working out okay but then
in 2019 they brought in Nick kandra who
served as the editor and chief he was
internally promoted to take on that
position and he started really focusing
on not just bringing back new things or
trying to recapture all glory but
creating something new because since
yatsi was still around and was reliable
zp coming out every single week they
knew that whoever was here for him would
stay here for him but they needed to get
new voices in here get new audiences in
give people a reason to come to The
Escapist other than just yatsi and over
the last four years he's done precisely
that while nothing has quite reached the
reliable numbers that Zero Punctuation
does various other things have hit
pretty high success rates for what are
admittedly as far as raw numbers go
secondary concerns things like the
output of a Creator who goes by Frost
who's done series like cold take and
stuff of Legends both of whom have
managed to crack six digits worth of
views there's the D andd campaign
Adventure is nigh which has a much
smaller audience but a very dedicated
and highly engaged audience which is
always an audience that you can get more
out of in terms of them being willing to
throw money at the project now the
company changed hands again because it
was sold from the Enthusiast gaming to
The Gamers group a little over a year
ago and what's more everything got much
more integrated the site before had
always kind of felt like it was a
collection of a number of independent
creators like there was occasionally
crossover like Stephanie Sterling and
yatsi had done a few things together
before Steph left the site but um by and
large it felt all very confined that was
like a crossover it didn't feel like a
team the way it's been the last couple
years has really felt like a team
they're on streams together they're
referencing each other's work they're
having very relaxed conversations it
feels very much like something special
was built up and earlier this week Nick
kandra was let go from The Escapist he
was not the only one fired Jack Packard
who was the DM for adventurous n the D
and D campaign him and a couple of
others were fired um but so far as can
be told from what I could find most of
the people who are now no longer there
weren't fired so folks like yatsi and
indeed the entire video creation team
literally every everybody involved in
the video
creation have resigned if they weren't
fired Escapist fired Nick who was the
person who had built it up into what it
currently is and then everyone who was
still there went okay well we're leaving
with him then what's gone on since then
all happened very fast they have already
launched a new project called Second
Wind group um the YouTube channel had
40,000 over 40,000 subscribers before it
even had its first live stream
explaining what it was they were even
planning to do which basically amounts
to um for what projects are wholly owned
by their original creators which some of
them are those will just continue to the
best of their ability um but with some
things such as say zero punctuation
there will be a new legally distinct
replacement for it being done uh on this
new project so the entire creative team
everyone who contributed to the YouTube
channel is all gone
why did corporate think it was a good
idea to get rid of the guy who had built
this thing into what it was well huh
we'll get into that but I don't think
they wanted this outcome because well
I'm going to make some parallels to some
other instances this was not a case of
they fired everybody they only tried to
really get rid of something that the
word is that corporate was never really
fully on board with Adventure is nigh
it's probably why that was usually the
main fundraising Focus whenever they
live stream was that it would fund ADV
Ventures I I think they had to keep
proving themselves financially that it
was worth doing but corporate never
seemed to be behind that very much and
so they got rid of the guy who had that
but also the guy who had made a team and
an organization that everyone liked to
work for and huge shock you get rid of
the guy who made the place an enjoyable
place to work and who was the one who
personally hired most of these people
pretty much everybody who wasn't
yatsi yeah
they don't want to be here if he's not
going to be there because even if you
just replace him and like aren't firing
them it's very safe for them to assume
well you're not going to keep the
atmosphere that we were enjoying working
in if you wanted to keep that you
wouldn't have gotten rid of Nick now I
want to reemphasize Escapist is not
strictly speaking only the YouTube
channel it is still it is still a
website it does still have written stuff
don't take it out on any of the writers
still employed by The Escapist they're
not responsible for any of this but
people who have been around in on the
internet for a while have seen something
similar than this before again while it
was not necessarily uh clear that they
wanted to scrap their entire video
making Department uh The Escapist was
probably better known for its video
output than the stuff written for its
website not to demean anyone who either
has or still is writing for them but you
can't help but think of stuff like
cracked or College Humor these things
that appeared to be successful were well
known for video content and had their
stuff completely shut
down so to make comparisons and also to
build into my greater points about why
does this kind of stuff happen at all
let's go over some of those real quick
I'm going to start with cracked now that
began as an actual magazine it was a
knockoff of Mad magazine started back in
1958 it launched a website in 2005 and
started to build momentum with its
written material a lot of it consisting
of lists and very irreverent articles
things like you know these weird
connections or these things you didn't
realize a little bit BuzzFeed but with a
much more deliberately humorous bent
they had comedy writers putting a very
harsh comedy spin on these things I am a
little bit uh biased in favor of the uh
cracked website I did actually in fact
uh full disclosure write an article for
them back in 2015 uh and was paid to do
so that article I'm still kind of proud
of even though what is in it is not
accurate to my life any longer and
hasn't been for a little bit but the
creation of that did effectively lead to
the creation of my first own written
work and published book so I I am a
little bit biased in their favor and
they were great to work with certainly
at the time as I said I was paid for the
piece but also they paired me with
somebody on their team to help me mold
it in terms of having it punched up and
jok ified to the degree that it would
play well with their audience I was
never encouraged to put anything false
or inaccurate to my life or experience
but just helping me with the
presentation of it it was a lot of fun
and I enjoyed doing it but regardless of
that what they kind of got even bigger
on was on YouTube in 2009 crack started
putting video content up on YouTube
including some incredibly successful
series such as after hours and then
later on some news now in 2016 cracked
was bought by the American broadcast
company ew scripts and in 2017 scripts
fired the entire video team to cut C
due to the losses at the company overall
they owned crack for a little more than
a year and a half and then they fired
the entire video team as I said to cut
cost this might seem all very strange
but like it was successful wasn't it
well yes but this was also around a time
when what YouTube was pushing and what
was playing well was in the process of
Shifting it was actually hitting a time
that was very difficult for anything
that was uh of high production value so
comedy sketches animation Etc got really
difficult because YouTube started
pushing longer material put out more
regularly which tend to tend to favor
things like let's plays and reaction
content which is part of why that stuff
has gotten so big in the last 5 to eight
years now much like what is currently
going on with The Escapist cracks their
actual website never stopped producing
content but the YouTube channel
effectively went dead for a while
scripts even after this cost cutting
would end up selling the company to
literally media in 2019 they have tried
to relaunch and bring back uh video
content starting in 2020 some of it has
done okay but it's doing nowhere near
the numbers but hold on to that fact
that scripts uh did all this for cost
cutting to cover for losses
because let's be clear about this and I
will come back to it it wasn't losses
suffered because of
cracked hold on to that we'll come back
to it let's talk about college humor
College Humor starts out as a website in
1999 in 2006 its parent company's
controlling majority of shares gets sold
to a company called IAC It's A Holdings
company also in 2006 College Humor
starts uploading YouTube videos in 2018
College Humor launched Dropout which was
a subscription service with more stuff
it had uh a couple of exclusive shows it
had longer versions of stuff behind the
scenes things basically uh an attempt to
say hey give us extra money if you want
even more of our stuff and want to help
us to do what we do and at the time that
kind of made sense because as I said at
the time due to the shift in YouTube's
algorithm and what they were favoring
yeah things had made it harder for
channels like uh college humor to be
profitable drop how would become home to
a number of breakout hits such as um
actually Dimension 20 and Game Changer
until College Humor was pretty much
completely shut down in 2020 so what
what happened in 2020 this all happened
at once and it it it happened so fast
that it actually unless you were paying
attention figuring out the full cause
and effect got a little dicey but here's
what happens so best as I understand it
in 2020 IAC was like this isn't making
the money that we would
like again doesn't mean it's not
profitable but it's not making what we
want so we're shutting it down now this
is one of the interesting quirks of what
happened in this case is that since this
was basically just killing the entirety
of col of college humor unlike say crack
where it's like well we'll keep the
website or The Escapist where yes they
still have the website killing the
college humor uh video creation team and
the YouTube channel and Dropout and all
that that was pretty much everything it
was so the brand itself suddenly became
worthless which actually meant that
iic was willing to sell the college
humor media company and brand to Sam R
who had been sort of heading up to the
thing but you know was working for IAC
so simultaneously like all this got shut
down and R had control of it now at the
time he only had the funds to maintain
employment of seven employees only one
of whom was on the creative side that
was Brenan Lee Mulligan everybody else
had to be cut but R for the past three
years has been rebuilding College Humor
now rebranded as Dropout to What It Is
Well to what it was before they killed
it and it appears to be a completely
self-sustaining and profitable model
again as I said the issue was not that
this was an unprofitable
thing it was it demonstrably is they are
successful once they no longer have Co
corporate overlords to answer to so why
are successful or at the very least
something that is not failing and isn't
losing you money why are these getting
shut down revamped killed why did that
happen to college humor to cracked why
did The Escapist think it was a good
idea to get rid of the guy who had
completely revamped into something that
was more successful than it had been in
years why because of corporate nonsense
let's get into that here's the thing I
think a lot of folks really don't
understand about corporate structuring
and especially in a world where we are
talking about parent companies and
conglomerates and a company might seem
like a wholly self- sustaining thing but
it's still owned by somebody else I
think the wisdom a lot of people carry
with them or an assumption a lot of
people make is that if something gets
shut down by a parent company it's
because that thing wasn't profitable
like it was kicking around the parent
company you know they either bought it
and it wasn't doing well or they tried
to build it up but it was losing money
it was a weight around their neck so
like you cut the thing that isn't
profitable
and sometimes yes sometimes that is what
happens but other times a business that
if it were independent if it were a
self-sustained completely isolated thing
like Dropout now is and like second wind
is going to
be it is
successful it makes the money it needs
to to pay its employees and to bring in
the revenue to keep sustaining itself so
it's clearly not a loss but can still be
shut down and often still called cost
cutting even though this isn't losing
them the owners any
money
why
because they don't view these as
independent companies as something that
needs to sustain itself and if it if it
does if it's if it's not costing us
anything and if it's bringing in money
oh well I mean why would we get rid of
them that's punishing the when they
didn't do anything wrong that's not how
they look at it these are just assets to
these companies when you're talking
parent companies when you're talking
Holdings companies when you're talking
conglomerates
Etc you are talking about people who
view these companies as assets
only and so when time comes around that
something has gone wrong even if it has
nothing to do with some of these
individual companies but like for
whatever reason money's
you didn't close a deal that you thought
you needed to you invested in something
that didn't work out well
or maybe you just didn't grow as much as
you told your shareholders that you were
going to suddenly it becomes expedient
to pad your books by cutting
expenses when your numbers come up short
when the when the numbers are run for
how much money you told your investors
and shareholders that you were going to
bring in this quarter and and it doesn't
make it a really quick way to pad those
numbers is to cut expenses is this thing
costing us money no but that's a bunch
of money we could cut it probably
wouldn't hurt that much not us it'll
hurt all the people whose jobs just got
lost despite the fact that they were
doing good work and and uh successful
work now that doesn't matter we got to
pad the books that's what you need to
understand the decisions to kill these
companies sometimes is a reflection of
the company itself the subsidiary
company failing but it is often more
often I would say a reflection of
Something's gone wrong at the corporate
level and we got to tighten the belt of
course they never tighten their own
belts they never take a pay cut at the
executive level they decide to get rid
of other people this is what happens
when you have these massive companies
and everything just gets bought once you
get a certain degree of success
something somebody just comes along and
buys you this is what happens they don't
care about you as aany you're an asset
and when times are tough you jettison
assets whether it is a asset that has
residuals that you're getting or not
like we got a jettison some assets uh
that one they don't care that there are
people attached to it they don't care
whether what they do as successful they
don't see you as people they don't even
see you as a company you're just an
asset on the books for them to sell or
scrap to pad their numbers that's why
this keeps happening and it's why it's
really rewarding to see things happen
like how Dropout has risen From the
Ashes of college humor of how I expect
second wind is going to Rise From the
Ashes of The Escapist now will The
Escapist continue to exist I don't know
we'll see they haven't been without Zero
Punctuation since 2007 and it has always
been the biggest draw so I don't know
what the heck they think they're going
to do now the simple truth is they
needed yatsi more than he needed them
but he never really had a reason to
leave before well they gave him one when
they got rid of the boss that he
realized he really liked working for and
I love this
detail I I want to think this was on
purpose the very first thing that was
put up on Second Wind uh their YouTube
channel was a live stream featuring Nick
and featuring yatsi and it went out at
the exact same time on the exact same
day that normally a new Zero Punctuation
would have gone live on The Escapist
that feels like a middle finger and as a
juicy bonus on this there was no new uh
Zero Punctuation that went live on The
Escapist at the time it should have not
because they didn't have them yatsi
rather famously is two weeks ahead on
his stuff so in theory The Escapist has
two more episodes of zero punctuation
that they could be
uploading and they didn't and I don't
think it was a deliberate Choice when I
tell you the entire video the entire
video team resigned I I mean at every
level front of camera voices production
backend everybody they all left I don't
think there's anybody still at The
Escapist who even has access to the
YouTube channel to be able to put the
video
live that's how much they screwed up
it's so frustrating as a creative as
someone who yes enjoys some of the work
of these people not just yatsi I
mentioned Frost I like his stuff I
haven't gotten heavily into Adventures I
but the bits I've heard of it it was a
lot of fun and there absolutely was an
atmosphere that really seemed like these
people enjoyed working with each other
that was just fun to be around I would
listen to the podcast on occasion it was
a great Dynamic it was a good
feel I'll happily follow them somewhere
else why would I stay at The Escapist
that's the other thing about these
corporations if they keep the thing at
all which they don't always sometimes I
just kill it but if they see value in
anything it's the
brand it's the name it's not the
talent why would you retain the talent
we've got the name we've got the brand
that everybody loves we can get rid of
the talent and just uh bring other
people in if we feel like it's worth
doing which is what crack has been
trying to do it's not really working and
that's not to not some of the newer
stuff that's on cracked and I kind of
feel bad for the people who are trying
to bring it back to what it was but the
people who were there moved on to other
stuff some of whom making you know
legally distinct versions of what they
were doing on there and doing it now
more successfully creative
companies when they get bought by these
parent
companies it is almost always eventually
the death of them sooner or later
they're either going to be shut down or
they're going to be gutted from what
they were it's going to become a shell a
name a brand where the talent that is
involved in it is not the ones who made
it something you cared about in the
first place let not say that new Talent
brought in can't also be good or can't
Revitalize something or taking a new
Direction I'm not trying to knock the
idea of bringing in new Talent heck Nick
did that with The Escapist that was a
major part of what he
did but as I get invested in the talent
I don't care what the name on the site
is this is why there are some names and
Brands and companies that are still
kicking around despite the fact that the
original company that that name was
attached to has not existed for a long
time you know how many different
companies have gotten to call themselves
Atari because the companies keep going
out of business and then the name goes
up for sale because they think the name
has value and there's some nostalgic
value yeah but you still have to
continue to do something anybody cares
about and they don't you might find
yourself wondering well if being bought
out by a different company if having a
parent company is such a bad
thing why do smaller companies do it why
do they even let themselves get bought
well there's a very simple answer but
there's also Nuance to it the very
simple answer is for money that said
there is Nuance to that um because while
yes the answer is ultimately they do it
for money the nature of why for money
has some fine-tuning for it because
there are some companies that are either
started by or eventually get Acquired
and controlled by somebody who just is
looking for a payout and if they're
looking at getting a one-time payment
that amounts to running the site for the
next 10 years but they can get all that
at once and then they don't have to do
the job anymore yeah a lot of people
will say it just just to take the money
but then you also have instances where a
company gets acquired but the upper
management or even the CEO or the person
who used to own it now stays on as like
head of a board or something because
they actually do care about that thing
and in cases like that you might be
looking at something that was barely
financially successful and this would in
theory give them a safety net and uh you
know a little Breathing Room possibly
this isn't just a buyout but a promise
to inject some more money into whatever
the project might be in which case this
might be thought of as a way to actually
build it into something more than it
could have been without being bought out
by somebody else that is still
ultimately for money in any case but it
is at least a situation where the money
is not necessarily intended to
immediately line somebody's pocket maybe
it is for the benefit of the business
but ultimately they get bought out for
money although sometimes they get bought
out for survival like I said sometimes
it might be a company that is really
barely making buy or sometimes you have
companies that are started up and they
actually don't even have a plan to
become successful they're started up
with a promise to get big and then the
company is sold on the promise of how
big it's going to be and that allows
owners to sell it before they even have
to turn into something profitable then
it's the responsibility of the parent
company it's a borderline Griff
sometimes that wasn't the case in any of
the three companies we're talking about
to be clear we're expanding out into a
bigger conversation at this point but
there's that but also beyond that saying
no to a buyout offer can actually be
dangerous there's the traditional
hostile takeover though that wouldn't
really apply in the cases of the kind of
companies we've been talking about
because a true hostile takeover involves
um stocks and shares short version of
how a hostile takeover works is that um
the heads of a company um you know they
have an offer to buy the company they
turn it down they don't want it and so
the people who made the offer then
basically go around the heads of the
company and start going to the
shareholders and the stockholders and
buying the stocks and shares directly
from them until they have a majority
share which case they control the
company even though the people who
managed it and didn't want to actually
sell them that's a hostile takeover so
if you're dealing with a company that
isn't big enough to have stockholders
and shareholders then that kind of
hostile takeover isn't going to be the
case that having been said it can still
be dangerous because there are more than
a few cases of companies who have made
offers to buy a smaller company been
turned down and have then in some way
deliberately sabotage that company
Bethesda did this with the video game
Studio human head so if you're a smaller
company saying no to a buyou might be
profitable you might think or hope that
maybe it'll be a good thing or you might
think if we don't take this they're
going to do something in some way to
make our lives more difficult and
annihilate us because often times when
these companies are bought sometimes
it's because it's thought of as an
addition to the portfolio doing
something that other companies we own
don't do or maybe may it complements the
stuff that our other companies do
or maybe it's seen as a competitor to
things the company are uh the parent
company already owns in which case well
we either buy them or we kill them
either way they won't be a competitor
anymore business is Cutthroat because
it's all profit driven it's about money
it's not about people it's not even
about individual businesses being
profitable because you can have
something where as an independent
business it would have been completely
profitable but it's owned by a parent
company and somebody at the high end of
that parent company decided to try and
SN money into nfts and it didn't work
and now they're going to cut hundreds or
even thousands of jobs from underneath
them to pay for their nonsense and their
mistakes that's the thing about being
owned by a parent company you can have
your job or your entire company that is
a subsidiary be killed because of
nothing you did wrong because of
mistakes made by people who do not know
your your name and don't give a crap
about you but who will make you jobless
to cover for their nonsense and to pad
their
books but every now and
then it goes in a nice Direction like
would drop out and now hopefully with
second wind made up of folks from The
Escapist I'll be keeping an eye on as I
said there's a fair number of people
involved in this who I've come to like
their work the case of yatsi for very
long time but case of some of the rest
of them more recently but I wish them
the best because while Escapist didn't
come in and fire them all it was very
clear that they were coming in to
completely upend what had been built and
what was continuing to grow to be clear
now from what Nick is saying they were
still hung up on the fact that zp did
numbers so much bigger than everything
else except you know it's the longest
running thing it's always been the
biggest thing and it's been here for
over 15 years I forget how long it's
been running at this point but a dang a
dang long time so yeah it's always going
to pull the bigger numbers but they
would use that as a cudel to judge him
for everything that he oversaw that
didn't do those kinds of numbers so even
though he built something enjoyable
sustainable
profitable didn't matter they just saw
numbers that's all they ever cared about
creatives need more control over what
they do because while I understand
understand that the money for a lot of
these projects has to come from
somewhere when you don't let creators
create then this is what
happens they just get cut because you
can't justify the Artistry of something
when somebody only cares about the
numbers and that doesn't mean that any
organization or Corporation is forced
should be forced to support a failing
artistic Endeavor no but you know again
this isn't a matter of oh we're losing
money this is a matter of we're not
growing as much or as fast as we want we
didn't make as much more this year than
last year as we told our investors we
would but that kind of starts to
dovetail into what was originally going
to be the video coming out today uh
talking about well in ification if
you know what that term means that video
is still going to come out and so I've
got more thoughts on all that and you'll
can wait for that uh it's probably not
going to be next week I I want to get
something like a little bit
more uh sort of thanksgivings e seasonal
out for uh next Saturday and then after
that we get into new episodes of Doctor
Who that I get to review so um be aware
that the uh inen ification video might
be a little ways off but it is already
shot and it is definitely coming but uh
yeah I'm getting to go off on corporate
nonsense quite a bit lately and while I
hate that I'm able to go off on this
stuff so much I ain't mad to about
it what are your thoughts on this
whatever they are on what happened at
The Escapist specifically about this
kind of thing about anything that I've
shared with you today drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
patreon pays the bills and shes that I'm
able to do this as my living I don't
have a parent company I don't have a COR
corporate Overlord and that's not being
said as a brag I could not do this
without the support from
patreon but even if you can't help me
out that way there's links other things
I do in the description and of course
like share and subscribe they all
help don't worry too much about it
though what I really want you to
remember is that you are
beautiful you are
valid you are
loved you are the council and I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned time to thank some patrons and
this time I'm going to say their names
as if I'm greeting them welcoming them
to a party Robin Moore zuman Lula
goddess Alida tck the thing that goes D
in the anime Ruth goer the Garian Oliver
B solitary pictures rrick Bogden Melinda
Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
forab likes the poodle Robin Powell t
love Tracy scrapit angry Casper Dave
Hall
Rosalyn Bennett have fun tonight and
thank you for your support I don't know
why I decided to do that this time but I
don't know I'm having
[Music]
fun
w